so abortion is really the story of the
day we learned late last night thanks to
a political report that the supreme
court plans to overturn both roe v wade
and planned parenthood v casey and this
will essentially do away with any kind
of federal fundamental right to an
abortion in most cases that women have
marjorie taylor green the radical
repugnant trumpist congresswoman
made a really wild statement just a few
days ago about abortion i just haven't
had time to get to it today but i want
to look at it this was a comment made
before we learned of the forthcoming
supreme court decision
in which marjorie taylor green
raises some really wacky religious stuff
where she says women get abortions
because satan comes up to them and
whispers in their ear
if you get the abortion
the guy who impregnated you will marry
you which of course
ignores the reality that if you're
pregnant because you've been raped
i don't know that you want the rapist to
marry you it's a vile vile statement but
it shows us the level of religious
delusion that exists for many of these
people now i will say again earlier when
we played the clip of marjorie taylor
green crying because she was so happy by
the supreme court decision that we
learned about
i said i think she's nuts
but if you believe abortion is murder
it's logical you would be very happy if
abortion is ending i understand that
this is just unhinged religious nuttery
that is you know it's about angels and
demons and ghosts and this type of stuff
take a listen
it's whispered softly and gently into
your ears and into your soul
and he tells you it's okay
and he says it's just just this one
thing
you're just gonna get it done get it
over with and then he tells you a
promise
he promises you
all these dreams that that you have in
your heart and that's how satan sells a
sin
and that's how he sells abortion he
tells a woman
that
all you have to do is you're just going
to go to this clinic just going to get
it over with you know and then you're
going to that guy he's going to stay
with you that that boyfriend or the guy
whoever he is
he's going to marry you sweep you off
your feet
so
first of all this is so specific that
it's extra strange i'm not saying she's
recounting a personal experience but it
is so specific that it is very weird
she seems to have no idea or concern
with the reality that there are people
in all sorts of situations who make
really tough decisions about what is
best for them
and sometimes it has to do with being a
victim of sexual assault rape sometimes
it has to do with a fetus with an
abnormality that would prevent ever
having anything close to a normal and
fulfilling life and would be suffering
uh sometimes it's
other things the point is
it ignores i mean this is this is like
psych ward stuff
and uh it ignores the reality of the
circumstances in which sometimes uh
women and families and and couples
choose to make really difficult
decisions but it's also paranormal and
bizarre and one of the unfortunate
things is you know earlier i said if you
believe abortion is murder it's logical
you would be happy for it to stop okay
but i understand that framework
on the other hand
if
you are making decisions or having
opinions about what civil law should be
based on your evidence-free belief about
angel angels demons demons ghosts and
satan
it's hard to imagine you could ever be a
productive and reasonable member of uh
of a legislative body to put it to put
it quite frankly and uh it's
extraordinarily dangerous and it's
extraordinarily disturbing